[Music]
it is the best-selling book in history
no volume ever written has been more
loved and quoted and its words sometimes
simple and sometimes mysterious should
always be studied carefully it is the
bible the word of god
welcome to bible answers live providing
accurate and practical answers to all
your bible questions
our phone lines are open if you have a
bible related question give us a call
now at 800 god says that's 800-463-7297
now here's your host from amazing facts
international pastor doug batchelor
hello listening friends would you like
to hear an amazing fact
on august 23 2022
a teenage pilot became the youngest
person to fly solo across the world in a
small aircraft
mack rutherford 17 landed at sofia
bulgaria after a five-month journey
across 52 countries covering 33
600 miles along the way mack who was
born to british parents but has grown up
in belgium encountered sandstorms in
sudan monsoon rains in india and spent a
night on an uninhabited pacific island
mack who began his epic odyssey on march
23rd describes some of the beautiful
scenes that he was able to encounter
from wildlife and national parks of
kenya to the new york city skyline
he landed wednesday august 23 2022 after
completing the feat
mack encouraged others to follow their
dreams no matter how old you are he said
work and move forward to achieve your
goals he added by the way his sister
zera is the youngest woman to fly solo
around the world
well that's something i tell you
that's a pretty epic journey yeah i've
you know i've had my pilot's license for
30 something years and i think you flew
with me once or twice i did yeah
and
you do your first cross country and
you're scared half to death
when you're flying by yourself between
three points on the map i can't imagine
all that would be involved in going in
and out of all of those international
airports where the air traffic is all a
little different and for a 17 year old
he must have had a lot of hours and
experience that's right when you look at
the map that you put that up on the
screen he didn't fly in a straight line
around the globe he kind of traced the
continent of africa that's a lot of
flying a lot of miles some of that was
by choice and some of it was because he
couldn't get the permits to land in some
countries so they had to skirt around
and other other times he wanted to see
certain parts of the world
but
you know i love flying if i'm on a
motorcycle i'm trying to find something
to jump or if i'm on my skis i'm jumping
and i was driving a truck today in the
hills and i revved it when i went over a
bump so i could
the sensation of flying i just love it
and you know a lot of people ask will
you be able to fly in heaven
and i think so you know you've got that
verse there in isaiah 40 31
and it says but those who wait upon the
lord will renew their strength they will
mount up with wings like eagles they'll
run and not be weary they will walk and
not faint
and i guess the other scripture would be
when jesus ascended to heaven that's
right they just ascended and of course
we know pastor like that angels fly we
have a number of accounts uh in
scripture i think of the one where
daniel was praying and an angel came
from heaven to earth being caused to fly
swiftly yeah so angel's flying
um you know you know the hymn that we
often sing in church we will soar to
world rock
of ages so
we know we're going to be going to
heaven but what about the other worlds
god has created it says we're caught up
that's right it's probably not in a
rocket that's right
well you know we do have a book that
talks about heaven this wonderful home
or the redeemed the bible tells us eye
has not seen nor ear heard neither has
it entered into the heart of man the
things that god is preparing for those
that love him but there are some things
revealed in scripture about heaven about
the home of the redeemed and our free
gift is all about that it's called
heaven is it for real and that is our
free offer if you'd like to receive it
all you have to do is call the number
800-835-6747
and you can ask for the book by name
heaven is it for real or ask of number
139 and we'll be happy to send it to
anyone here in north america
now we do have those who are listening
outside of north america and if you'd
like to read the book we encourage you
to go to the amazing facts website just
or dot amazingfacts.org.com and you'll
be able to read it there on our free
library and it's called heaven is it for
real and pasadena we want to greet those
who are not joining us we have folks
watching live on af tv
also watching on um
youtube and then on facebook on your
facebook page doug batchelor facebook
page also on the amazing facts facebook
page
and this is rebroadcast on some other
networks so we want to greet all of
those who are watching wherever you
might be however you're getting this
program and of course the many who are
actually listening
on radio this program started as a radio
program and we want to greet those
listening on land-based stations and
also those listening
through the satellite radio system so
what would that absolutely let's start
with the word of prayer and we will get
to bible christians
dear father in heaven again we thank you
for this opportunity that we have to be
able to open your word and study and
lord it's always exciting to be able to
come to the scriptures we know that you
have promised to be with us and we
desire that we might be led into a
clearer understanding of bible truth so
be with those who are listening wherever
they might be and guide us here as we
search the scripture in the studio we
ask this in jesus name amen amen now
friends this is a live program so if you
have a bible related question the number
here to the studio is
800-463-7297 again that's
800-463-7297 or 800 god says
and that'll bring you here into the
studio
and we'll be able to take your question
on the air so i think we're ready for
our first caller we've got anthony
listening in new york anthony welcome to
the program
hello good evening pastor evening
um my question uh is with regards to
acts chapter 2
verses 16 through 18.
and i'll try to i'll make this brief um
basically i know that you know you see a
lot of
uh on tv or different you know churches
where they start to call people
profit and you know i guess as a
uh
honor type thing or things of that
nature i've heard some people claim to
have you know the gift of prophecy or
claim to be prophets basically what
based on acts chapter 2 verses 16
through 18 i want to know
what constitutes a prophet
um especially if knowing that in the
last days people will have the gift of
prophecy does that automatically make
them a prophet or
you know right i just want some clarity
yeah good question and for our friends
that are driving or something if you
don't have a bible handy let me read
that for you real quick this is uh
during the day of pentecost peter gets
up and he starts to preach in acts
chapter 2 and i'll start with verse 16.
but this is what was spoken of by the
prophet joel the people are wondering
about you know this manifestation of the
spirit
and the kind it'll come to pass in the
last days says god that i'll pour out my
spirit on all flesh your sons and your
daughters will prophesy
your young men will see visions your old
men will dream dreams and on my
menservants and my maidservants i'll
pour out of my spirit in those days and
they will prophesy and i'll show wonders
in the heaven above and signs in the
earth beneath and by the way peter there
is quoting from joel chapter 2.
and
this is not only something that happened
here in acts
when the holy spirit was poured out of
pentecost it may repeat itself in the
last days
now jesus has warned us to be careful
about false prophets
but the fact that he says watch out for
false prophets indicates there will
probably somewhere be true prophets or
jesus would have said don't listen to
any prophets in the last days
so how do you know if a person is a true
prophet
first of all not every time you find the
word prophesy does it use the term
in the context of like an old testament
prophet that was making a prediction
uh to prophesy like an acts i'm sorry in
first corinthians 14 it's talking about
preaching means to proclaim prophets
that means to proclaim on behalf of
another
and so
a lot of times when it talks about the
gift of prophecy in first corinthians
it's talking about being able to preach
and teach
but it is also true there will be
prophets in the last days
you know even uh last prophecy in the
old testament behold i send you elijah
the prophet before the great and
terrible day of the lord that's a
prophet prophet
so how do you know a true from a false
prophet first we have a lesson that
talks about astrologers and psychics so
look we'll send you a free copy of that
because it's got a lot of verses in it
but there's some criteria
deuteronomy tells us that if a prophet
makes a prediction it doesn't come true
probably a false prophet
if
if they're asking for a fee to give you
a prophecy it's probably a false prophet
if they're giving you a bill
and if their lives are not in harmony
with the word so if a person is living a
you know a scandalous life and yet they
said i'm a prophet
their lives are going to be following
the model in the bible their teachings
will not contradict the bible if they're
true prophet so in that lesson we're
offering it gives the criteria of how do
you identify a true from a false prophet
the study that we have it's called does
god inspire astrologers and psychics and
we'll be happy to send that to anyone
who calls and asks the number again is
800-835-6747 that is our free resource
line as to the study guide does god
inspire psychics and prophets or
astrologers and it actually gives the
biblical principles to determine a true
prophet from a false prophet it's all
there in the study guide well thank you
for your call anthony next we have um
patrick listening from canada patrick
you on the air
good evening pastors
evening i have a i have a question about
the mosaic law
so it's taken from luke
chapter 19 verse
and um there's just also another verse i
couldn't find it but it's about we're
gonna mix materials um
cutting of beard
uh tattoos and
um
and something else i forgot uh sorry
cutting of bears and tattoos i just like
to find out if those apply to us today
even though we're gentiles welcomed into
the family garden
by accepting him
yeah well it says there in leviticus
chapter 19 verse 28 you shall not make
any cuttings in your flesh for the dead
nor tattoo marks on you i am the lord
there are clearly some things that you
might find in the book of leviticus that
are connected with ceremonial laws and
those things would be
obsolete nailed to the cross we don't
sacrifice lambs anymore circumcision is
not required
but there are also some very practical
laws that are sort of self-evident you
know god says don't follow the practices
of the pagans
and if the pagans were mourning the loss
of somebody they'd do everything from
cut off a finger to cut their flesh like
the prophets of baal when they wanted to
appease their god they pierced
themselves to the blood gushed out
and they are they tattoo themselves
and you know your body's the temple of
the holy spirit and god doesn't want us
putting marks i know what i'm saying
that's probably extremely unpopular
because i bet you 10 of everyone
listening has a tattoo these days
but
the bible i think means what it says
i am the lord don't put any tattoo marks
on you
um you know god intended us to
live forever and to advertise for him
so
yeah our bodies shouldn't really have
graffiti on them
and the practical truth is that a lot of
folks who get tattoos they
they regret it
to get a tattoo requires you to pierce
ink under your skin it's not necessarily
the healthiest thing some people end up
with some kinds of skin cancer or
something from that
and
yeah i just
i i think it's kind of a self-evident
truth this is what the pagans used to do
they would mark slaves with tattoos this
i just came back from auschwitz in
poland where they had the nazi
concentration camps and i remember
meeting friends of my grandparents that
were jewish they had the
tattoo marks still on them
so
yeah i don't know why christian
christians are doing that it says pretty
plainly don't do it
okay very good well thank you thank you
patrick for your call uh we've got caleb
listening in new york caleb welcome to
the program
hello thank you pastors how are you
doing tonight doing good
and your question um my question my
question is a little bit more of
embarrassing
i'm a christian
i grew up in a church but like lately i
let like
all the worries of life discourage me
from
um studying
and praying as much and just all the
worries i'm just afraid like if i go
back to god like that deliberately i'm
afraid if i go back to god god won't
accept me anymore i'm just is there like
an encouragement like verse i can read
and something that encouraged me
because i'm a little nervous about this
and
i'm afraid yeah let me tell you just
this uh
this sabbath i preached
on luke chapter
starts i believe with verse 9
and jesus tells a parable two men went
up to the temple to pray one was a
pharisee and one was a public and
publicans were the
the outcasts of society they are called
great sinners
jesus often talks about the harlots and
the publicans so you've got these two
men one very religious and one is sort
of like the
uh you know the gang member of the
culture
and they both go to church
and the pharisee he prays and says the
lord i thank thee i'm not like other men
extortioners adulterers or unjust
or like this tax collector back there i
pay tithe of all that i've got i fast
twice a week
and the publican the tax collector he
would not so much as lift up his eyes
into heaven but he smote upon his breast
and said lord be merciful to me a
sinner. jesus said that man went down to
his house forgiven his prayer seven
words in english lord be merciful to me
a sinner
and god had mercy on him because he
repented his heart was humble if you go
back to god and you say lord i am sorry
please have mercy on me the bible
promises that he will
a contrite heart god will not despise is
what psalm 51 says so if we humble
ourselves and if our hearts are contrite
meaning if we're um we're meek poor in
spirit
then god is a merciful god if we're
sincerely repenting he will sincerely
forgive
you know we got a book and it talks
about this it's um
well actually several that we could
offer but i'm thinking of the one three
steps to heaven kind of lays out what we
have to do to reconnect with christ as
our personal savior we'll be happy to
send this book to you or anyone that
calls and asks the number to call is
800-835-6747
and you can ask for the book it's called
three steps to heaven we'll be happy to
send it to anyone here in north america
a good question thank you for calling
we've got um aidan listening in
tennessee aidan welcome to bible answers
live
hey um
so my question is regarding repentance
uh
so
i haven't i'm a relatively new believer
but i'm wondering
is repentance necessary for salvation
um and i've heard different definitions
of repentance and i've also heard other
teachers say you must repent and trust
the jesus to be saved
but i'm just wondering you know like
what
what is the importance of repentance
good great good question very important
question it's often neglected today
well let's just think about it this way
for a second
aiden the first words that jesus speaks
when he begins to preach
is
repent for the kingdom of heaven is at
hand indeed the first thing john the
baptist said when he started preaching
he was went out in the wilderness and he
told people repent for the kingdom of
heaven is at hand when peter is
preaching in acts chapter 2
and the people are convicted by the
words of peter and they say what shall
we do peter said repent and be baptized
and so
repentance was like part and parcel step
number one repentance represents a
sorrow for sin and a willingness to turn
away from it
and so when we come to jesus
we should have some sorrow for our sins
and what we've done to the lord
and be willing to repent
what is it ezekiel 18 he says turn ye
turn ye why will you die
so god is calling us to turn from our
wicked ways and live that's what
repentance means now the bible also
tells us that it's the goodness of god
that leads us to repentance so you don't
have to wait to feel oh i feel terribly
sorry for the sin we can go to god and
say lord please help me
recognize that i am a sinner and
give me that genuine repentance it's
more than just you know a casual prayer
it you want your repentance to be deep
and meaningful you think of an example
in the bible after david sinned with
bathsheba you have an account of his
prayer
and that is a heartfelt earnest prayer
that is a type of repentance that
doesn't just come from ourselves it is
it is the moving of the holy spirit upon
the heart so we can ask for that we can
ask for the holy spirit to convict us
and come to god and have true repentance
yeah and david was on his face for seven
days i don't know that that's required
of everybody but that pretty evident he
was sincerely sorry for what he had done
you know we've got a study guide that
talks about this it's called save from
certain death and it's steps to
salvation how do we experience that true
repentance we'll be happy to send this
to anyone who calls and asks the number
to call again is 800-835-6747
you can ask for the study guide it's
called save from certain death and we'll
get it in the mail and send it to anyone
here in north america we got
aaron listening from new york
hi aaron welcome to the program
good evening pastors
my nephew has been living a careless
life and ended up in prison back in
april and he's still there waiting trial
and for about about a month now he has
been getting dreams almost every day
he's been getting dreams about things
like a helicopter an umbrella a shower
curtain
pepper spray
and then he's been getting dreams of
animals like a
pelican a snake and a dragon
and after that he's been getting dreams
about random numbers
like the number eight zero eight
he told me that one of his friends said
that he has been dreaming angel numbers
but i don't think that's biblical hey
tell me why he's been getting all these
dreams and
do they have any
significance all right well i you know
of course i
i won't venture to say specifically why
he is getting certain dreams i'll tell
you what causes dreams a dream can come
from the lord there's examples in the
bible where god spoke to joseph in a
dream matter of fact he
spoke to both josephs in the new
testament and the old testament in a
dream
and
a dream can come from the devil
job describes that
horrifying experience where you have a
nightmare
dreams
typically and this is in ecclesiastes it
says a dream comes from the multitude of
business
so if you've got a lot of thoughts going
on during the day
then you may dream about some of that
during the night
and
you know dreams is something like your
brain defragmenting at night now if a
person is under a lot of stress
as your cousin you said who is you know
awaiting trial and going through a big
change in his life
yeah that could mess with your mind and
and
you could have a lot of strange dreams
that doesn't mean they're prophetic
so i wouldn't try to read a lot into
that
if god gives you a dream that is really
a message i think you'll usually know it
you won't have to kind of wonder if i
wonder if that shower curtain and that
number in my dream meant something if
god is trying to message you in a dream
he's also going to give you an
interpretation and you'll know it
okay very good next quarter that we have
is anthony listening in pennsylvania
anthony welcome to the program
yeah you're on the air
good afternoon hi
well good evening pastors how are you
doing good
and your question tonight
my question is revelation 21
verse 1.
[Music]
uh it says now i saw a new heaven and a
new earth
for the first heaven
when the first earth had passed away
also there was no more sea
my question is
what is the sea and why is it
specifically talking about
no more sea in heaven
well
obviously there is water in the new
earth because you get to the last verses
in the bible and it says
you know
there's a river
that proceeds from the throne of god
and rivers run somewhere they typically
run into a body of water
but there's a difference between a lake
freshwater lake and a sea
and you know the typical briny sea that
we can't drink
that stings your eyes
i think there's going to be no oak vast
ocean separating loved ones there
probably will be beautiful lakes and
rivers and streams in the new earth it's
going to be like a park but there may
not be you know right now two-thirds of
the world is sea it wasn't like that
when god first made it before the flood
i think the reason that you've got all
the water that covers the earth now is
all the water that used to be below the
earth
in
caverns it says that there are misused
to come up out of the earth
that after the flood the tectonic plates
you know
weighed down and it came up i don't know
what happened geologically but
i don't think you're going to have that
in the new earth so when he says there's
no more sea think about no more salty
water vast oceans that will separate
loved ones
you know the bible says speaking about
the flood the fountains of the great
deep broke open yeah and so there was a
lot of water from under the the earth
that came up and covered the land yeah
all right very good next question that
we have is robert robert listening in
washington robert welcome to the program
thank you pastor ross
yes send your question tonight
uh one
i guess kind of different question was i
was reading a few days ago in luke 21
and talks about one of the signs being
um
the seas and the waves roaring and
i
i think david talks about the lord is
mightier than mightier than the ways of
the sea or is more powerful than the
ways of the sea
um
so
my question was
what makes the seas and the waves
roaring
so special for the second coming
you know i think that could be an
example of maybe a dual prophecy
uh for one thing
when it talks about the sea and the
waves roaring in revelation it talks
about the beast came up out of a stormy
sea or is that in daniel that says that
yeah and or maybe both and the woman
comes up out of the sea
so
um
when it talks about the seas in
prophetic terms it can mean turmoil and
storms in the world like those angels
holding back the winds of strife but i
also think because jesus is talking
about earthquakes he's talking about
very real geological natural disasters
that and men's hearts failing for fear
though looking at
things like the tsunami that took place
in 2004 where you've got you know 240
000 people die
most of the world's population lives on
the coasts
and so it may be one of the natural
disasters christ says there'll be
plagues there'll be earthquakes in
divers places and in luke he says the
sea and the waves roaring and i think in
luke he says there'll be signs in the
heavens also
so
uh just you got the things unraveling in
the last days and also an increase of
storms i mean storms are created over
the sea hurricanes winds destruction and
you know i think we've seen an increase
of some of these devastating storms and
of course tsunamis and earthquakes these
all signs that jesus gave pointing to
the soon coming of christ yeah i think
it's interesting in one part of the
world they call it a hurricane
in another part of the world they call
it a cyclone and another part of the
world they call it a typhoon but they're
all the same thing that's right
big storms dangerous storms well i'm
just looking at the clock pass today we
might not have time to take one more
caller but we want to remind you of our
free offer tonight uh the program's by
no means over we're just going to take a
short break but if you missed the
beginning of the program our free offer
tonight is a book entitled heaven is it
for real
and we'll be happy to send this to
anyone here in north america the number
is 800-835-6747
you can ask for off number 189 or just
ask for it by name heaven is it for real
we'll be happy to send it to anyone here
in north america now pastor you
mentioned that you've been out of town
for a couple of weeks i know you're over
in europe what were you doing there yeah
karen and i were in poland we were
speaking at a um
doing some evangelistic meetings there
in a town not far from krakow
and
then we went from poland to the czech
republic and spent some time preaching
in prague beautiful city
and very glad karen could join me this
time and then went from there to a like
a christian businessman they're looking
for it's called we call it asi it's an
opportunity for christmas businessmen to
get together and look for ways to share
christ through their various businesses
very creative ideas
so i just loved loved being there and uh
yeah it's it's fun to see
things are finally opening up where you
can travel without the restrictions
we've encountered the last couple of
years so it was really nice before the
pandemic we had all this international
travel schedule that kind of came to a
standstill
and it started to build up and now we're
trying to catch up on the all these
invitations so it was nice to get out
again
all right well i think we've got a break
coming up and if you have questions i
think we have some lines open just call
800-463-7297
and call with your bible question that's
800 god says we'll be back in just a few
moments don't go away
[Music]
stay tuned bible answers live will
return shortly
[Music]
millions of people believe that planet
earth is on the verge of some apocalypse
that will plunge the world cities into
chaos
in response
thinking people everywhere are wondering
if it might be a good time to locate
their families outside of the congested
metropolitan areas
in my new book heading for the hills a
beginner's guide to country living i do
my best to provide a biblical balance
i'd like to share with you some of the
crucial things you'll need to know
before you head up for the hills
i'd also like to identify some of the
practical things you look for in buying
a piece of country land how to develop
water power and a garden all while still
seeking to save the lost this book has
some very valuable information for
anybody that's ever considering country
living
order your copy of heading for the hills
call 800-538-7275
or visit afbookstore.com
batchelor was the teenage son of a
millionaire father and show business
mother yet he was living in a cave he
had everything money could buy
everything but happiness but all of the
fun and excitement he enjoyed left his
life out of control
his search eventually led him to a cave
above palm springs that became his home
while doug scavenged for food and
garbage bins his father owned a yacht a
learjet and an airline
but in his cave home he discovered a
dust-covered bible
as he began to read he soon learned of
his true purpose in life
the richest caveman is the extraordinary
true story of doug batchelor that tells
how a rebellious teenager who once lived
in a cave became a tremendous soul
winner for jesus christ it's a thrilling
testimony of the transforming power of
god's word to order your copy of the
richest caveman call 800-538-727
or visit afbookstore.com
you're listening to bible answers live
where every question answered provides a
clearer picture of god and his plan to
save you so what are you waiting for get
practical answers about the good book
for a better life today
[Music]
if you have a question about the bible
or living the christian life call us now
at 800 god says that's 800-463-7297
now let's rejoin our hosts for more
bible answers live
welcome back listening friends to bible
answers live and if you've tuned in
somewhere along the way this is a live
international interactive bible study
and you're invited to join us
with your bible questions just call 800
god says that's 800-463-7297
i am doug batchelor my name is john ross
and we're going to go to the phone lines
our next caller that we have is lori
listening from indianapolis laurie
welcome to the program
thank you thank you for taking my call
um i have a question about when we die i
was always under the impression that we
go straight to heaven but in reading
some of the scriptures it says that
they are asleep in christ uh do we wait
when we die and go when he comes back
or just go straight to him good question
i'm really glad you asked it's a
confusing subject for a lot of
christians because you can walk through
a christian cemetery in the back of the
church and just look at the tombstones
and you can see there's confusion one
tombstone will say something to the
effect
our mother
resting in the arms of jesus
waiting for the resurrection trump and
the other two stunned will say our
mother dancing on golden streets or
something like that so some of them put
the dead immediately in the presence of
the lord others say r.i.p rest in peace
and folks go which is it
the confusion comes in because i think
people forget
god lives outside a time and when you're
dead you have no consciousness of time
it's not like a restless sleep
so when a believer dies
their next conscious thought
is the resurrection
but we don't get raised one by one it
says in first thessalonians 4
then the dead and christ rise
and so we rise together at the coming of
the lord
and
so you know if you have a loved one and
they died believing you can find comfort
knowing their next thought
is going to be the presence of the lord
but we live in time
time hasn't happened yet god lives
outside of time he's i am he's a hundred
percent present in any part of time
so
um yeah they're in the grave sleeping
it hasn't happened yet
acts chapter 2
peter is talking about king david he
says david this is a good king who had
died a thousand years earlier david says
he is dead buried not yet ascended to
heaven
that's pretty clear they're sleeping
until the resurrection when the lord
descends from heaven then they did in
christ rise now pastor i think some
people are confused by the verse and you
you alluded to it says paul says to be
absent from the bodies to be present
with the lord but paul is not saying the
minute you die the next thing is you're
in heaven as some sort of a spirit or
soul what does he mean by that yeah and
paul is the one also who said that
don't sorrow concerning those who are
asleep
so paul refers to death as asleep he's
simply saying that
when you die
your next conscious thought is the
resurrection because you have no
consciousness in death and then you look
in ecclesiastes chapter 9 i think verse
5 it says the living know they'll die
the dead know not anything hezekiah says
those that go down to the grave do not
praise the lord so the dead are asleep
jesus said our friend lazarus is asleep
and we have a free offer on we do
does that help lori does that make sense
it does it it was a whole different
concept from what i was raised to
believe yeah right thank you thank you
as long as it's from the bible that's
what matters you know we have a study
guide it's called are the dead really
dead and we'll be happy to send this to
you lori or anyone who is listening all
you have to do is just call and ask the
number is 800 835 674 and you can ask
for the study guide it's called are the
dead really dead that's 800-835-6747
one more time ask for the study guide
are the dead really dead and if you have
a computer just remember we've got a
website it's called
deathtruth.com and you can go to that
website and there's a number of great
resources and sermons and all the
scriptures there deathtruth.com
next caller that we have is philip
listening in arkansas philip welcome to
the program
hey good evening thanks for having me on
yeah my question is uh in the last part
of ezekiel i think chapters 40 on
through the rest of the book god gives
the ezekiel some detailed instructions
for
building a temple
and my question is why when they went
back to rebuild after the captivity did
they not rebuild using those plans
yeah ezekiel he outlines in ezekiel
chapter 40
and actually i think a couple chapters
near the end of the book
this massive temple and it goes into
great detail giving them measurements
he also talks about a river
that is so wide
that you can you know you barely cross
it you go a mile out and you're only up
to your knees so that clearly
was not in jerusalem
and so
when ezekiel talks about this temple
and it is something of a conundrum for
bible scholars but
um part of the answer i would say look
in revelation 11
and in revelation 11
john says i was given a reed like a
measuring rod and an angel stood and
said rise and measure the temple of god
the altar and those
those who worship their measure of the
people
it's like a judgment
so
clearly in revelation he's got this
measuring rod exactly like what ezekiel
had in chapter 40. he's going around
measuring everything
and it's probably because ezekiel 40 is
talking about a spiritual temple that's
supposed to be vast um
and of course you find different types
of temples in the bible jesus spoke of
himself and he said destroy this temple
and in three days i'll raise it up and
he's talking of himself the new
testament says the church is the temple
of the living god individuals are
temples and we know there's a temple in
heaven and it's involved in the judgment
so i see i think a lot of scholars seen
there's some symbolic application to
more than just the temple that was
rebuilt in jerusalem obviously there's
there's more spiritual application
especially when you tie it in with some
of the symbolism that we see in
revelation yeah all the other plans that
god gave his people in the bible if it
was something literal it was always
built like an ark
or the golden ark and the temple so
those things were built i don't think
god would have given ezekiel all these
things if it was supposed to be
literally built
unless it really just had a spiritual
application
all right great question we've got
candace listening from rhode island
candace welcome to the program
hi
how are you
hi pastor
so i have a question i am a
36 year old newly found widow
and
i was curious to know at my age yes i'm
young
um i'm nowhere near ready to date move
on
in the future
is it lawful for me to
get married even though i can't
have children
yeah absolutely 40. the the purpose for
marriage is not only
that you can procreate
i mean that you know god did tell adam
and eve be fruitful and multiply
but um
you know there obviously some people
can't have children their marriages are
still marriages
even if they don't have children either
by choice or by biology
and so
you know if
companionship and love is a very big
part of it the bible says it's not good
for man to be alone it doesn't say it's
not good for man not to procreate
so companionship and what the word man
there's talking about like anthropos
actually that would be the greek i
forget what the hebrew would be but it
means mankind or humanity
uh so
uh yeah there's i i don't think there'd
be anything wrong with the person
getting married simply for the
companionship men and women sort of
complete each other you know we got
different gifts and uh
um
unlike some of the contemporary theories
today about men and women gender not
really existing i think the bible is
clear
gender is very real and men and women
are wired differently and we sort of
complement each other
and i think that partnership is a
wonderful thing now some people spend
out the rest of their days men and women
as widows and they still have fulfilled
christian lives
but there's nothing wrong with getting
married and not having children
especially today
you know it says woe to those that are
with child in the last days because
it could be extra hard
okay very good well thank you for your
call candace we've got rick listening in
north carolina rick you're on the air
yes guys how you doing
doing well
how can we help well
well my question is on first
thessalonians um chapter 4 verse 14
um when he said um that god would bring
back with him those who are asleep
and just to spare some light on that and
a few probably texts that go through
that just to clarify that chapters
yeah
so when he says god will bring with him
paul is talking about a sequence here
he's saying don't be of don't sorrow
regarding your loved ones that have died
that would be verse 13. don't be
ignorant i don't want you to sorrow as
others that have no hope if we believe
jesus died and he rose again even so god
will bring with him
so when jesus comes he's got the
resurrected with him
then he tells why that is for this we
say to you in our verse 15
by the word of the lord that we who are
alive and remain until the coming of the
lord by will by no means proceed
perceive means go before
those who are asleep
for the lord himself will descend from
heaven with a shout the voice of the
archangel the trumpet of god the dead in
christ rise first that means before us
then when we get there they're with him
see what he's saying
then we who are alive and remain will be
caught up together with them so when it
says he will bring them with him it's
because when we're caught up to meet him
they're with him now they've been raised
but it's all happening in the same event
and also from the context uh if you're
thinking of from god's perspective god
is in heaven jesus comes to the earth
the dead in christ are resurrected the
righteous are changed and jesus brings
the resurrected ones and the saved with
him back to the father so from the
father's perspective
those who are resurrected come with
jesus back to heaven it's not necessary
don't think of it as jesus bringing the
resurrected ones out of heaven down to
the earth rather christ is bringing the
resurrected ones from the earth up to
heaven to where the father is
does that does that make sense rick
yeah are there other verses that can um
just clarify a little bit better
yeah you mean the sequence of the
resurrection
yeah like yeah
yeah let me take you to go to first
corinthians chapter 15.
and um this to me i think is a very
strong passage let me just see if i can
find the right verse for you
all right here you look in verse 35
someone will say how are the dead raised
up
and you got celestial bodies spiritual
bodies
second man um flesh and blood cannot uh
here we go i'm in verse 50.
let's see i'll go to 52.
well i'll go to 51. behold we tell you a
mystery we shall not all sleep this is
first corinthians chapter 15 51
we shall not all sleep but we'll all be
changed in a moment in the twinkling of
an eye at the last trump the trumpet
will be sound sound and the dead will be
raised incorruptible is that clear
and we will be changed for this
corruptable these bodies that get old
will put on incorruption this mortal
will put on immortality
and so
and he makes it pretty clear i'm looking
for another verse where it tells us that
uh
um that
atom
is an example
and let me say here
uh-huh say something
pass through that's why
right is that the one you're thinking
about no i'm thinking about when he says
but this is the order
about the uh
resurrection friends i've still got jet
lag i think he told you i was in europe
last week
and so right now
uh i'm operating with
half my cylinders aren't firing
um
yeah well romans chapter six verse five
i'm just looking up results oh here i
found it okay yeah it's halfway through
it's in first corinthians chapter 15
verse 15 22 for in adam all die even so
in christ shall all be made alive but
each one in his own order and so
he was asking about the order and this
is for rick each one in his own order
christ the first fruits afterward
those who are christ's at his coming
when do they rise
at his coming so that to me i think is
one of the very clear slam dunk verses
now all the verses you mentioned and i
think a whole lot more are found in a
study guide called are the dead really
dead not only talks about what happens
when a person dies but it also talks
about the resurrection of the dead and
we'll be happy again to send this to
anyone who calls and asks the number is
800-835-6747
and we'll get that in the mail send it
to you if you're listening in north
america next quarter that we have is
henry listening in new york
henry welcome to the program
yes good evening
my question is
back in the biblical days
mary and joseph uh is there any people
living today uh who
theory uh are they are they related to
well i'm sure there are people that are
related it tells us both mary and joseph
descended from the tribe of david a
tribe of judah which is where david was
from and david specifically and very
likely because you look at the the kings
solomon who is a descendant of david had
hundreds of wives and concubines
so
i think that their dna
of uh david
which you know ended up in joseph and
mary
is in the world today now of course
jesus had no children so if you're going
to say is there any physical dna that
you know mary passed on no joseph did
have other children
prior to marrying mary
uh it talks about jesus brothers and
sisters that they're technically half
brothers and sisters
um but um i guess you'd say step
but um no there was uh nobody came from
mary and jesus
right from that line it started
all right next question that we have is
brandon listening from kentucky brandon
welcome to the program
hi pastor hi um
jeremiah 4 23 says i beheld the earth
and indeed it was without forming void
so my question is what is the condition
of the earth at the end of the thousand
years at the resurrection of the wicked
yeah well you found it there
if you look in that's one example in
jeremiah chapter 4
it tells us that
and if you go to verse 23 by itself
it makes it sound like well this is
talking about the second coming but you
keep reading and it says i beheld the
mountains is the 24 and they trembled
the hills moved lightly indeed there was
no man the birds of heaven were fled
i beheld the fruitful place was a
wilderness and all its cities were
broken down and you say
at what
at the presence of the lord and by his
fierce anger the coming of the lord
devastates the planet and it says the
hills and the mountains melt before him
as he comes
so
the world stays in that condition but
it's almost
you know it goes into darkness during
the 1000 years and satan and his demons
are chained down here so at the second
coming you have the righteous taken to
heaven you have the wicked those who are
alive destroyed with the brightness of
christ coming the dead wicked while they
just remain in their graves
and you have the devil and these angels
sort of bound to the earth kind of
imprisoned
here on the planet for a thousand years
and then at the end of the thousand
years you read about the third coming
where the new jerusalem descends in
revelation chapter 21 and it's at that
time that jesus sets his feet on the
mount of olives and it opens up and
forms a great valley you read about that
zachariah
and the new jerusalem comes to rest the
wicked all resurrected for the final
great white throne judgment in
revelation 20 and then final destruction
comes upon the wicked so those are sort
of the sequence of events that we see
laid out in bible prophecy we do have a
study guide that talks about the
thousand years it's called a thousand
years of peace and we'll be happy to
send this to anyone who calls and asks
the number again is eight hundred eight
three five
seven
you can call and ask about a thousand
years of peace it's talking about that
chapter that we read in revelation
chapter 20. and you'll find that
interesting thanks for your call brandon
we've got andrew listening in wisconsin
andrew welcome to the program
hi how are you doing
really well
uh pastor uh doug i have a question um
out of the book of acts chapter 21
verses 19 to 24
um is the apoc when the apostle paul is
coming into jerusalem
he's confronted by james is paul keeping
the law of moses in this particular
verse when he's um asked to
take a vow
well yeah there there were
laws that you find in the old testament
where a person could take a vow it tells
us earlier that paul shaved his head
because he had taken a vow he did that
on his own he wasn't required the first
time just says that he had chosen i read
it today actually
that he had chosen to take a vow and
then now he comes to jerusalem
and
the accusation is going around among the
jews that paul is teaching people to
abandon the law
and they said so that they won't think
that why don't you go ahead and shave
your head so they see that you're you're
taking a vow
paul was not against doing that but it
was sort of he was sort of capitulating
to the pressure from the pharisee
christians believe it or not they were
pharisees that had converted to christ
and they wanted
all the gentile christians to keep the
laws you find that in acts chapter 15.
so
paul was trying to accommodate the
apostles that were not wanting to
anger the
the pharisee or the more uh law bound
jewish christians but you know we also
find an interesting verse in first
corinthians chapter nine this is the
apostle paul
and he says um for though i am a free
man and have made myself a servant to
all that i might win even more and then
he says and to the jew
i became as a jew that i might win the
jews
and he says those who are under the law
meaning the law of moses that i might
win those who are under the law and to
those who are without the law meaning
the law of moses
uh he was as one without the law in
order that he might win those who are
the gentiles so as far as conscience
would allow and it was right for him to
do he tried to connect with the people
that he was trying to reach
now
by seeing paul do that example he
followed certain customs that the jews
followed but he didn't require the
gentiles to follow those same customs
for example circumcision was very
important to the jews paul's very clear
what gentile believers there's no need
for circumcision right
so
hopefully that helps a little bit
uh andrew and uh
thank you for your question all right
we've got tom listening in chicago tom
welcome to the program
good evening pastor good evening my
questions are now matthew chapter 10
verse 23
if somebody else how can i explain that
to
my other others
all right matthew 10 verse 23 i'll go
there real quick
and uh let's see here
he says when they persecute you in this
city flee to another
for surely i say to you you will have
not have gone through the cities of
israel before the son of man comes
um
i think that he's saying basically that
there's going to be plenty of work to do
until jesus comes
indeed jesus says in matthew 24
the gospel will be preached in all the
world for a witness and that would
include the tribes of israel and then
the son of man will come
it's interesting that today there are
very few christian churches
in israel even though you've got
christian pilgrims from around the world
going there
most of the
israelis do not believe in christ
you know it's also interesting here that
when jesus is referring to the to the
phrase of
um
israel it's true that there are still
many many jews that have not yet
received the message or received christ
as their personal savior but in the new
testament israel is also used for those
who profess faith in christ you've got
spiritual israel right and even amongst
those who claim to be christians there
are those who have not really come to a
full understanding of what what the
truth is what the gospel is so there's a
mission field not only to those who have
never heard the gospel
but there also there's also a mission
field to those who have the word of god
who have heard the gospel but they have
not heard it correctly they haven't
received the full gospel just like the
jews they had the bible but they didn't
understand the truth of the messiah of
christ
so it's a broad application not only to
literal jews but i think to even
spiritual jews or christians there is
still a work of evangelism that needs to
take place even amongst those and we've
actually got a little book we can offer
called spiritual israel that explains
that israel includes more than just
literal jews
the numbered call for that is
800-835-6747 you can ask the book it's
called spiritual israel and we'll be
happy to send that to anyone who calls
and asks
all right next caller that we have uh
we've got darla listening from idaho
darla welcome to the program
hello pastor thank you so much for
taking my call
my question is
if i can explain it
right
um
i'm just wondering about jesus's clothes
okay so um
i'm wondering
um
his clothing was changed to
seamless when he was on the mount of
transfiguration
or
has he always had seamless clothes does
this
yeah because it's saying that at the
cross when they gambled for his clothing
they didn't want to tear his cloak
because it was without seam is that what
you're talking about
yes yes yeah you know there's no
statement in well it does say that when
he was on the mount of transfiguration
his clothing was glowing brighter than
the sun at noonday
and brighter than any soap could get it
but i don't think there's any comment in
there that something happened where that
suddenly is closed at that point became
seamless it's an interesting thought i'd
never thought of before but i don't
think anything in the scripture says
that i think it has more to do with the
style of of the clothing or the robe
that christ had
it was more expensive to weave a a robe
without a lot of seams now maybe there
was probably one scene but in compared
to what was more common amongst the
people it was a more expensive type of
weaving more expensive type of robe more
valuable that's why the roman soldiers
didn't want to tear it apart
so i think that's more of what it's
referring to it was a somebody had given
him a beautiful
uh robe that christ wall
all right well thank you appreciate your
question do we have time for one more
let's try okay we've got austin
listening in texas also welcome to the
program
uh thank you pastors uh first off i just
want to say thank you for everything
y'all are doing just leading us to
christ
um i gotta i kind of got a far out there
question though so i hope this doesn't
put you in a tailspin there pastor doug
all right um
the the theory that the world is flat
with the dome or the firmament above it
supported by pillars they also say that
the stars reside in the dome
they use verses like in genesis job and
psalm and chronicles and samuel
throughout the bible kind of supporting
this flat earth theory i just kind of
wanted to
get your two cents on it
all right well thank you yeah it's my
answer it's probably worth about two
cents uh but
it's really simple for me
the world is round
uh you know we started with an amazing
fact about a teenager who just became
the
youngest person to fly a plane solo
around the world
my friends that believe that the earth
is flat
they must also think that all the pilots
in the world are conspiring together
with this great secret
and i'm a pilot and i can tell you that
the world is round
uh pastor ross has been on airplanes
around the world probably several times
huh
yeah yeah
so they're taking meadow they're taking
allegorical verses in the bible where
job and others will talk about the earth
being on the pillars of the earth or
something well job actually says the the
circle of the world god yes it's over
the circle yeah so there are verses in
the bible that describe the earth as
being round yeah and spherical yeah
so hey friends don't go very far this
popular program is actually
on so many stations we've got to sign
off in stages so goodbye to our
satellite friends we'll be back with
questions for the others in just a
moment
thank you for listening to today's
broadcast we hope you understand your
bible even better than before
bible answers live is produced by
amazing facts international a
faith-based ministry located in granite
bay california
[Music]
welcome back friends those who are able
to stay by we've got about two minutes
and we're going to be taking some of
your internet questions that you sent in
so if you have a bible question you'd
like to email it to us the email address
is bail questions at amazingfacts.org
so pastor like the first question that
we have is from someone in the uk
and johan is asking in acts chapter 16
16 verse 18 there is a story of a
demon-possessed person
that was exalting god and proclaiming
that the disciples had a message of
salvation why did paul want to quiet her
and why was the demon saying these
things
yeah not just this case where you've got
a demon-possessed girl that was
highlighting that paul and silas were
servants of the most high god
but when jesus
first started his ministry he was in a
synagogue and some demon-possessed man
stood up and said jesus son of god we
know who you are
and i think
several occasions the demons would speak
out and says they would
name him yeah you know the devil what
makes him so deceptive is that
um
he will sometimes support the truth and
what he's declaring but then he ends up
getting people's attention because of a
supernatural power and then he twists
and distorts things so
the devil will blatantly lie the devil
will sometimes act like he's supporting
the truth don't forget even balaam the
prophet gave some true prophecies and
ended up betraying
the people of god so sometimes they'll
win confidence that way sure what she
said was true but paul did not want the
advertisement of the devil okay another
question that we have this one is when
people go to church
and they start going into any he calls
it a fit and they collapse in church
and they say this is from god his
question is is this from god or is this
a manifestation of another spirit
well i've got to be careful not to make
a sweeping statement that says in every
case when a person is slain in the
spirit as they say i used to go to
pentecostal churches
sometimes you wonder what spirit
because in a lot of demonic
services people can be slain in the
spirit where they lose all control
but there is also an example in the
bible where the spirit of the lord came
on saul and he fell down prophesied took
off all his clothes and he seemed
totally out of it
so you know there may be cases in the
methodist revival there were some people
that just seemed to be
swoon under the power of the spirit but
that's different than people writhing
and you know convulsing like snakes on
the ground
anyway
hey friends hopefully that was helpful
thank you so much god willing we'll be
coming back again in a week to study the
word of god with you
[Music]
bible answers live honest and accurate
answers to your bible questions
[Music]